-Whoo! Hi!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you!
Please, sit down.
You don't know
how the set's gonna go.
[ Laughter ]
Whoo! New York City!
We back open!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow! Man!
I went out last night, and
I've been hungover,
uh, for years.
[ Laughs ]
Here's a little secret.
When I was 13, growing up
in Puerto Rico,
I almost drowned.
Don't worry, I made it.
But that's
the second scariest thing
that's ever happened to me,
because, last week,
a stranger got in
a revolving door with me.
[ Laughter ]
I'm sorry.
If you're not laughing,
I assume you're a terrorist,
because that's not what we do
in this country.
It was a circular one,
like the four-corner one,
and I walked in real confident
like I'd used it before.
And midway through, it jammed.
And I heard a voice
that was not mine.
[ Laughter ]
I heard a voice go,
"What's the holdup?"
[ Laughter ]
I was just like,
"Miss, you're the holdup.
Who let you in here?!"
[ Laughter ]
It's a one-person wedge.
We all learned this.
It's real basic, and
the lady got real nervous,
because she turned around
and tried to push the door
the other way.
But that's not how
those doors work, is it?
[ Laughter ]
So I had to like,
"Hey, [Smooching] focus."
Like, Gather back in the right."
[ Laughter ]
But to anybody who saw us,
we just looked like
a couple who needed a moment,
like we were arguing
and this was the only
quiet place we could find.
Man, I caught my first flight
since B-CVD,
and people still flying tight.
Like, people are flying
like our parents used to fly.
Like, efficient.
Like, nobody's just, like,
flying for funsies.
Like, you better have a purpose.
Everybody boarded quickly,
nobody made eye contact.
They were just like,
"Fauci didn't say
we could get it through the eye,
but what do I know?
So just, like,
buckle up and let's go!"
Like that.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't think
we were gonna make it,
'cause the dude flying the plane
was walking around the terminal,
slouching.
[ Light laughter ]
I know he's called a pilot,
but he didn't have pilot energy.
You know what I mean?
That's a cool job.
Pop your chest out,
believe in yourself.
[ Laughter ]
The dude was just walking around
just like,
"I guess we'll try this again,"
like that.
[ Laughter ]
Mnh-mnh.
Your carry-on look empty.
You look like you
ain't trying to land.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you're a pilot,
you're better than us.
Show it.
[ Laughter ]
That's one of the few jobs
you can brag
and we just have to take it.
It's like pro athletes --
not golfers,
but, like, the other ones.
[ Laughter ]
The people making
Girl Scout cookies
and pilots --
the only ones we trust.
[ Laughter ]
The scariest part was,
we were all seated,
everybody had
that nervous energy,
and right before we pulled back,
the pilot jumped
on the microphone,
and he was like, "Um,
this is your captain, Robert."
I was like, "Um?"
[ Laughter ]
"Wait a minute,
you open with 'Um'?!"
[ Laughter ]
"Dude, you can't be hesitant.
Not right now.
We told you we on edge.
Captain Robert?
Nah, you Bobby."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I did witness real maternal love
on the flight,
which is always dope.
I love that.
I don't have a kid,
but I love
when a parent,
like, gets defensive
and just, like, hulks up and
just like, "No, I made this one.
Step back."
This is what happened.
I'll never forget it.
I was seated in 26-A,
because I have status.
Um...
[ Laughter ]
The dude next to me, 26-C,
not with me.
Very important, Jimmy.
Uh, baby crying, 24-A.
Babies cry, and
dude next to me just goes,
"Ugh! I hope this baby
doesn't cry the whole time."
But he said it loud enough
like he was hoping
that the baby might hear.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Like the baby might go,
"Oh, my God, I'm so sorry.
I didn't realize
it was nap-nap time.
I'll keep it down."
[ Laughter ]
Dude said that.
Baby doesn't respond.
But who does respond is
the mother of this baby.
So, 26-C goes, "I hope the baby
doesn't cry the whole time."
And then we just hear
an angelic voice from 24-A
go, "What mother-flubber,
you don't cry?"
[ Laughter ]
And it was
the most logical thing
I've ever heard
on how to defend a baby.
[ Laughter ]
People don't like babies crying,
because they get to
do it in public,
while the rest of us
have to wait for a shower.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
I tip my hat to parents
after this year.
This past year, man,
that stress was different.
Just on virtual learning alone.
I've been helping my niece out,
because she recently found out
I only work
15 or 20 minutes a night.
[ Laughter ]
She was like, "Oh,
this guy got some time."
And it's stressful,
because before the parent,
I imagine if your kid
got a bad grade,
you would go,
"Hey, what happened?
Did you not study?
Who taught you?"
But now this blame go 50/50.
[ Laughter ]
So, like, now your kid
get a bad grade,
you don't have a dumb kid.
"We a dumb family."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Speaking Spanish ]
Have a good night, guys.
My name is Rojo Perez.